COMMITTEE -- AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THIS IS THE TELLING ENERGY
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR WEDNESDAY
JUNE TWELFTH -- WE HAVE -- THREE
ITEMS ON OUR ON OUR FILE FOR
TODAY. TO OUR CONSENT -- THAT
WOULD BE STE SB FOUR NINETY
SEVEN BRADFORD.
AND SB FIVE OH SIX HUESO.
OF MR HUESO WHILE WE WAIT FOR A
QUORUM -- WE WILL HEAR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON SP -- FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN BIO METHANE GAS
CORPORATIONS.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS -- IMPORTANT
BILL.
WILL HELP -- CALIFORNIA MEET
IT'S CLEANER TARGETS -- SP FOUR
FIVE SEVEN IS A BILL TO SUPPORT
THE STATE'S INNOVATIONS.
ON BY A METHANE -- THIS IS A
STRATEGY AMONG -- SEVERAL OF THE
STATE'S -- STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS.
IF YOU RECALL LAW LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED AS BEFORE.
TO FORTY MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
WERE VERY HELPFUL AND AND
GETTING THAT BILL PASSED LAST
YEAR WHICH REQUIRES A CPC TO
ESTABLISH.
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS FOR BY
METHANE.
THIS BILL IS A COMPLIMENT TERRY
MEASURE BUT MUST MUCH MORE
MODEST EFFORT THIS BILL EXTENDS
A SUNSET DATE. FIVE FIVE YEARS
FROM.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX OF FOR AN EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT -- WILL
ALLOW BILE METHANE PROJECTS TO
INTERCONNECT WITH THE GAS
UTILITY PIPELINE SYSTEMS.
ANY OF THOSE PROJECTS.
ARE UNDER WAY BUT WILL NOT BE
BUILT IN TIME TO QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM -- THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURAL
INVESTMENTS ARE TAKING PLACE
CURRENTLY THAT HAVE DRAWN
INVESTORS OUR STATE TO HELP US
WITH THESE GOALS.
UNDER UNDER THE PROGRAM.
OF THESE PROJECTS CAN RECEIVE UP
250% OF THE PROJECTS
INTERCONNECTION COSTS.
ONLY AFTER THE PROJECTS ARE
BUILT AND OPERATED AND OF COURSE
AS I MENTIONED -- SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE UNDERWAY BUT NOT
WILL NOT BE READY IN TIME TO
MEET THE PROP PROGRAMS -- OF
DATE.
THE STATE WIDE FUNDING FOR THE
MONETARY INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS IS
CAPPED AT FORTY MILLION TOTAL.
SO THERE IS ALREADY THAT --
BUILT INTO THE LAW [inaudible]
AND AND AS I MENTIONED OF THE
PROGRESS OF THE PROGRAM'S MOVING
FORWARD -- SIMPLY -- EXTENDING
THE DATE WILL ENSURE THAT THESE --
VERY IMPORTANT PROJECTS ARE
AFFORDED THE TIME THAT THEY ARE
AND THAT THEY THEY NEED TO
COMPLETE CONNECT AND OPERATE
THEIR INTERCONNECTION PROJECTS
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES TO US.
NEED A CAR. FOR SEVENTY NINE
WEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HOLDEN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICK A
POOR AND THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS -- THE RG COALITION IS
COMPRISED OF OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE LEADING MEMBERS FROM
EACH SECTOR OF THE INDUSTRY
INCLUDING ORGANIZED LABOR
UTILITIES AND THE PRODUCERS OF
OVER 90%.
OF ALL RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IN
NORTH AMERICA.
HI WINNER CONNECTION CALIFORNIA
IS UP TO SIX TIMES AS EXPENSIVE
AS IT IS IN NEIGHBORING STATES.
DUE TO THIS THE INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN FORCED TO CONSTRUCT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR ENERGY
PRODUCTION FACILITIES OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IRONICALLY MUCH OF THE ARE IN G.
THAT IS PRODUCED IS THEN
DELIVERED BACK INTO CALIFORNIA
FOR USE IN IT VARIETY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS.
THE BY A METHANE MONETARY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WAS CREATED TO
HELP COVER THE COST OF
INTERCONNECTION IN ORDER TO EVEN
THE PLAYING FIELD AND ALLOW US
TO INVEST IN AND CREATE CLEAN
ENERGY JOBS. FOR CALIFORNIA SO
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN PRODUCE MORE
OF THE ARE IN G. THAT IT
CONSUMES AND REALIZE THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF DOING
SO.
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CLIMATE CHANGE COPING
PLAN REPLACING FOSSIL FUELS OR
BIO METHANE AND MAKING IT COST
EFFECTIVELY AVAILABLE IS KEY TO
REDUCING SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS.
DECREASING DEMAND.
NO NATURAL GAS AND HELPING THE
STATE ACHIEVE OUR TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE TARGET. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A ROLE
CALLED [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HERE PATTERSON PATTERSON
HERE BURKE.
BURKE HERE CARILLO.
CARILLO HERE CHEN.
CHEN HERE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
EGGMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
I THANK MAYES.
MURATSUCHI YOUR CITY HERE QUIRK.
QUIRK HERE REYES.
SANTIAGO.
TEAM.
TEAM HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A CORE -- WILL TURN
YOUR NEXT WITNESS TO HOLDEN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE TIM
CARMICHAEL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IT JUST IT TEARS HEARD ME SAY
THIS A FEW TIMES THIS YEAR BUT
LAST YEAR MARY NICHOLS CHAIR THE
A RESOURCES BOARD TESTIFIED IN
TWO DIFFERENT CLIMATE HEARINGS
IN THE CAPITAL.
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE A STRATEGY
FOR SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS WE DON'T HAVE A
CLIMATE STRATEGY IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS A PROGRAM AND THE EXTENSION
AT THE SENATORS BILL IS
PROPOSING IS REALLY A CRITICAL
ELEMENT OF THAT SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
STRATEGY BECAUSE WE NEED.
PLACES TO TAKE THE FUEL THAT IS
CREATED BY -- THE VARIOUS
PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDER
DEVELOPMENT.
THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO PUT IT INTO INTER
CONNECTED INTO THE PIPELINE --
AND THE FACT IS IT'S TAKING
LONGER THAN ANYONE OF ANY OF US
WOULD HAVE LIKE TO GET SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS UP AND RUNNING.
THEY CAN'T CLAIM THIS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TILL THEY'RE UP AND
RUNNING AND THIS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT YOU KNOW IT'S HAD A
BROAD BASE OF SUPPORT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS -- BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE THE CAL RECYCLE AND
THEIR BEER ESTIMATING THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED ABOUT A HUNDRED
PROJECTS.
STATEWIDE -- TO ADDRESS ORGANIC
WASTE THE END AND I'M NOT TALK
ABOUT COMPOSTING THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE COMPOSTING TYPE
PROJECTS.
AND SO THIS FUNDING.
YOU KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
SUPPORT A DOZEN MAYBE TWO DOZEN
INTERCONNECTS OVERTIME
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT.
BUT THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM WE
ENVISION IS GOING TO BE NEEDED
GOING.
FORWARD OVER THE NEXT DECADE
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF THE SCALE
OF THE CHALLENGE AND THE NEED
FOR THIS -- PART OF THE SOLUTION.
TO THE PIPELINES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WE HAD
AMENDMENTS YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THEM AND YES MA'AM.
HOW WILL NOW TAKE -- TESTIMONY
OR COMMENTS -- ME TO SERVE YOU
WELL SURE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VALERIE TO RELIVE Là
HOSTS -- FOR PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY -- IN SUPPORT
FOR REASONS MY COLLEAGUE AS
STATED IT THIS IS SIMPLY AN
EXTENSION OF TIME NOT ADDITIONAL
MONEY PDS SUPPORTIVE OF GREENING --
OUR PIPELINE AND THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY WE CAN THANK YOU.
MOVE THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF MARKET PREY
ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES
WE WANT TO ASSOCIATE OUR SUPPORT
WITH THE PRIOR WITNESSES AND
DRIVE VOTE.
MADDIE MUNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AG ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MUCH OF THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY AND MORE THAN FIFTY
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
IN DIFFERENT STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
I GET AFTERNOON -- PREVIOUS IN
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WILL BE BRIEF --
WE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT
WE RAISED IN DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AND AND
DIFFERENT CONTACTS WITH RESPECT
TO THE STATE SUBSIDIZATION OF A
CLUSTER PROJECTS OF GAS
INJECTION PROJECTS.
AND OF THE KIND OF PERVERSE
INCENTIVE OF INCREASING OUR
PRODUCTION OF MANY WERE -- FOR
THE PURPOSES OF CREATING GAS
WHEN WE REALLY SHOULD BE
SPENDING OUR DOLLARS AND OUR
MONEY AND OUR SUBSIDIES ON
REALLY GREENING THE ENVIRONMENT
REALLY GREENING ENERGY SECTOR.
AND LOOKING AT ZERO EMISSION AND
AND NO MISSION I'M TECHNOLOGIES --
AND AGAIN -- UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO'D LIKE.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION -- JULIE
JORDAN WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO OTHERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR TESTIMONY I TURNED BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE -- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS DOCTOR BURKE -- JUST
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IT'S MUCH BETTER.
A AND PEOPLE ARE GOING TO CHANGE
OUT THEIR STOVES AND THEIR
HEATING SYSTEMS TOMORROW.
SO THE MORE OF THIS MATERIAL WE
CAN GET IN THE PIPELINE THE
BETTER OFF WE'RE GOING TO BE.
THANK YOU.
YOUR MURATSUCHI.
COULD YOU LOOK AT SOMEONE
ADDRESS THE THE CONCERN RAISED
BY THE THE OPPOSITION IN TERMS
OF INS INCENTIVIZING MANEUVER
PRODUCTION.
HI YOU KNOW I I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW TO RESPOND TO THAT I I THINK
IT'S HIGHLY HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT
SOMEBODY IS GOING ON REYES MORE
CATTLE SIMPLY TO PRODUCE MORE
MOVEMENT OR JUST.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN BUT I MAYBE VIEW MIND.
ONE FIVE FIVE THE REPRESENTED
I'M I'M I'M BEING TOLD THAT A
BETTER ANSWER WOULD COME FROM
THE ACTUAL DAIRY INDUSTRY.
I'M SURE THE SENATOR HAS A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS TO SAY ON THIS
TOPIC BUT I WOULD JUST ADD THAT.
THE NUMBER OF DAIRIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY BEEN
DECLINING FOR MANY YEARS AND
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SEEN
THE NUMBER OF CALORIES IN THE
STATE DECLINE ALSO.
SO NONE OF OUR DATA SUPPORTS THE
ASSERTION THAT THIS WOULD
INCENTIVIZE -- LARGER AND MORE
JERRY -- PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA WILL DO THAT THE
BETTER ANSWER [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU KNOW JUST GOING TO
SAY AS AS IS THAT YOUR BAG AND
MY FOR A FIRST YEAR WE LOOK AT
ISSUES OF MILK PRICING AND I
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE PRICING AND
AND THEN I THOUGHT I EVER WOULD --
BUT YEAH THE THE THE ISSUE
REMAINS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF A
LOT OF OUR ARE VERY PROPER
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS AND A
pTHAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE'VE SEEN THE AMOUNT OF
DARES GO DOWN BUT THENABOUT
HOUSE HAVE NOT WHICH MEANS THAT --
THE SMALL GUYS CAN'T CONTINUE TO
COMPETE AND SO THEY GET SOLD OUT
BY THE LARGER CORPORATE FORMS --
WHICH YOU KNOW IS IN A BAD WORD
IS BECAUSE THAT IF YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO FARM IN BULK -- SO I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
INCENTIVE TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF THE NEWER CONSUMED -- ARE
PRODUCED BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT AS
COST EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE TO
CONTINUE TO TO PRODUCED -- DERES
UP PRODUCTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS ONE MORE
AVENUE TO BE ABLE TO DO IT.
AS MY FRIEND DR QUIRK SAID IN
ADDITION TO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ELECTRIC GRID OVERNIGHT WE'VE
GOT CAL IS HERE WE'VE BY.
I LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT WE STILL
WANT AGRICULTURE TO CONTINUE TO
THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
SAFEST.
FOOD AND THEN -- AND FARMING
PRACTICES.
SO WHY NOT CELEBRATE THOSE AND
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE IT'S COST EFFECTIVE SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THANK YOU.
OF THE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS -- MR TING.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION COULD
COULD YOU GIVE ME EXAMPLES OF
THE PROJECT THAT HAVE BEEN.
FUNDED OR JUST WHAT TYPES OF
FIVE PROJECTS HAVE ALREADY
GOTTEN FUNDING.
SO I BELIEVE TO HAVE BEEN
OFFICIALLY FUNDED ONE IS AC. R.
NAHR WHICH IS IN THE CALIFORNIA
TOWN OF PARIS -- NOT TO BE
CONFUSED WITH THE WOMEN'S WORLD
CUP -- BUT THAT IS IT IS ONE OF
THE MODEL PROJECTS FOR THE WHOLE
COUNTRY ACTUALLY THEY ARE TAKING
A MUNICIPAL ORGANIC WASTE FROM
SEVERAL CITIES.
PROCESSING IT -- PUT PROVIDING
SOME OF THAT FUEL FOR THE REFUSE
TRUCKS THAT SERVICE OF CITIES
AND PUTTING SOME OF THE FUEL --
RENEWAL RENEWAL AFTER GAS INTO.
THE PIPELINE -- THE SECOND ONE
IS THAT CALTRAIN AND THAT'S IN
PIXLEY CALIFORNIA AND THAT IT'S
A DAIRY PROJECT THAT IS
CURRENTLY INTERCONNECTED AND
INJECTING INTO SO CAUCUSES GRID
[inaudible]
QUESTION SO.
SENATOR YOU CAN CLOSE TO BE LIKE.
I'M SORRY -- I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A COMMENT AND THAT IS THAT
THE FACILITY IN PARIS IS.
VERY IMPRESSIVE FACILITY AND NOT
UP TOP OF MY HEAD I DON'T.
RECALL THE NUMBER OF JOBS THAT --
THAT THEY HAVE THERE BUT THEY'RE
SIGNIFICANT.
I TO JUST WANTED YOU KNOW STATE
THAT THAT YOU KNOW I WANT TO GET
TO THESE.
YOUR MISSION YOU KNOW GOALS OF
THE STATE TOMORROW.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE QUITE A WAYS
FROM GETTING THERE AND THERE'S
THIS IN BETWEEN OPPORTUNITY I
THINK FOR THE BIO FUELS IN
GENERAL -- TO SERVE A PURPOSE --
AYE AYE YOU REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT.
IS KIND OF A HUB FOR BIO FUEL
DEVELOPMENT -- AN AREA THAT I'VE
REPEATEDLY SAID IN CENTER WEST
ON I SHARE -- REPRESENTATION OF
THIS AREA THAT'S GOT THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT SAY CALIFORNIA 16%.
A WE HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THOSE ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME MEETING SOME OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AS WELL SO JUST
WANTED STATE -- MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND AND THE REASONS
WHY.
THE IF NORTHERN GOT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORTS THE
EFFORT TO CONTINUE TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES IN TIME FOR THE
PROJECTS TO DEVELOP RESOURCES
AREN'T.
REALIZES RESOURCES NO ADDITIONAL.
OF DOLLARS ARE BEING ADDED TO
THIS AND SO I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE -- TO AS THERE'S BEEN
STATED CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOBS TO BE CREATED AS WELL
AS ADDRESSING.
ALTERNATIVE WAYS -- TO GUITAR
GOALS.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS PLEDGES --
SIMPLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND I JUST WANT TO RESTATE THAT
WE DO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED.
BY THE COMMITTEE IN JUST ASK --
FOR EVERYONE SUPPORT TODAY THANK
THANK YOU WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL
ON THE MOTION.
SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HI PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CAMILLE I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
AM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
AT WATER GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
MAYES.
MAYES I MERCI G..
MAYOR SEARCHING NOT VOTING.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM [inaudible]
TING HI.
MOTION CARRIES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON YES AND NOW WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT THAT'S SP FOUR
NINETY SEVEN BRADFORD.
AND THAT IS -- DO PASSED TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH RECOMMENDATION.
AS A CONSENT ITEM AND SB FIVE OH
SIX HUESO PROPOSED AS CONSENT TO
PASS TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
VOCAL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
CONSENT CALENDAR SB FOUR NINETY
SEVEN OF THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND THE SECOND ITEM IS SB FIVE
OH SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I'D PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CLEO AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CUNNINGHAM.
IN HIM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
WATER GARCIA I MAYES.
MAYES HI MERCI G..
BURKE LINE WORK I REYES.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE TEEN.
TEEN HI.
OF THE MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CARRIES -- WE WILL
LEAVE -- THERE ARE THIRTEEN
VOTES IN FAVOR WILL WAIT --
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD I WILL GIVE A ABOUT THREE
OR FOUR MINUTES -- LET ME ALSO
SAY THAT -- THE UTILITY AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE WILL BE HOLDING
A BILL HEARINGS ON JULY THE
THIRD IN ADDITION TO THE
MEETINGS ON THE FIRST AND THE
THIRD WEDNESDAY OF THE MONTH SO
THAT WILL.
I CAN'T -- PROMISE THAT THOSE
MEETINGS WILL FLY AS QUICKLY AS
TODAY'S BUT THIS THEY WILL HAVE
AN EXTRA MEETING IN THERE FOR
JULY [inaudible]
SO.
YOUR OFFER.
YEAH.
IN ALL DAY.
WHAT ELSE COULD?
HAVE.
THREE YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
WE SAVE THE BEST FOR LAST.
ARE WE HAVE -- SB FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN HUESO THAT BILL IS ALPHA
BUT WE WILL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RAY AS WE AT THE BUILDING
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL TOLD.
THIRTEEN TO CHECK TO LEVEL
[inaudible] TWO TWELVE ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CALENDAR.
SB.
FOUR NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THAT THE MAN DID NOT DO
PATH TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CONSIDERATION. TO GO TO CONSENT
CALENDAR AND THEN WE HAVE.
SB FIVE OH THING.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
YES I RARE STUFF.
AND THAT HAS -- FOURTEEN OKAY
THEIR PHONE TWO FOURTEEN VOTES
IN FAVOUR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IT IS ADOPTED.
AND THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED